um
and and maybe maybe just my second one
and then i'll turn it over to you
to uh to ask the questions um but i
would love to just
you know sort of understand how you you
know you have you know in the daunter
investor you talk a lot about
the concept of heads i win tales i don't
lose a lot
um and you know in terms of margin of
error i would love to just maybe delve
into you know examples of
how you thought about sort of margin of
error because i think it's a really
interesting concept and then also in
context of
you know thinking about spawners or
growing businesses you know
i think if you have an example they tend
to be smaller and maybe a wider range of
outcomes uh for these businesses and so
how you sort of
you know think about margin of error in
context of
you know the spawners or these
you know the businesses you're not
focused on
yeah i mean i think you know buffett
says uh the focus really should be on
the downside
uh you know so you really have to make
sure that the downside is
very solidly protected and if the
downside is well protected
almost the upside almost takes care of
itself
uh so so you know when when i wrote the
tandoo investor
and i wrote about the patel's i mean my
own my own
experience as an investor as an
entrepreneur
and this is not just my experience it's
the experience of almost all
non-venture-backed startups so venture
back stratos make up maybe
one tenth of one percent of all the
startups maybe less than that
non-venture backed startups is what is
everything that drives the us economy
the non-venture lifestyles
and so the people who
start these businesses
everyone thinks they're risk takers but
they are the opposite of risk takers
entrepreneurs do not take risks
they do everything in their power to
minimize risk
and so they try to put the urge as much
in their favor
uh when they take this when they take
these these bets so for example
in my own case when i started my
business i pulled thirty thousand for my
for a 401k
account and i was 24 years old i wasn't
worried about my retirement savings at
that point
and uh i took 70 000 in credit card debt
and and i researched a bank personal
bankruptcy laws at the time they've
changed those laws
since then but at that time if you
declared bankruptcy
uh personal bankruptcy uh pretty much
everything was cleansed and you couldn't
declare bankruptcy again for seven years
which actually meant that you became a
better credit
for people to give your credit card
themselves because they knew you
couldn't screw them again
they knew they got screwed once but they
knew they couldn't get screwed a second
time for at least seven years
so you're actually your credit improves
so the way i looked at it i said okay
this hundred thousand
that i'm putting in let's say it blows
up let's say
the business fails right so i say the 70
000
is visa and mastercard are my venture
campus okay
and they are just great venture
capitalists they took no board sheets
they never asked me what i'm doing this
was beautiful
and if it didn't work i could just go
and
declare personal bankruptcy and it would
just wipe clean
and the 401k you know i'd get a job and
we'd rebuild that so
and i was single at the time and when i
left my job
my employer told me my boss told me
we would love to have you back if you
come back they said
they told me when your business fails
they didn't say if your business fails
they told me monish when your business
fails you can come back
we'll give you like a 20 raise we'll
give you a promotion
and you'll be all set we'll be happy to
have you back so i said this is great
okay the business fails i declare
bankruptcy i go back to work
i have a better pay so where is the risk
right so this is how the brains of most
early stage entrepreneurs which are
non-venture-backed work
venture-backed guys they've got an iv
they're different universe
forget about that so iv trips are really
bad for you because you know
it's better to spend your time getting
customers
than trying to get some vc to fund you
i always feel it's better just get
customers so anyway what i'm trying to
say is that
early stage businesses most early stage
businesses that the entrepreneurs who
start them
do not take risk they do everything in
their power
to minimize risk and of course what
happened with me was the business never
failed
i never went back to work i paid visa
mastercard off
they got very lucrative you know
interest terms
everyone was hacked you know no problems
so i think i think the same framework
comes across in investing
because just like you know as an
entrepreneur you try to minimize
downside risk
the same thing in investing you should
always look at
what happens if things don't go the way
you're thinking what's the protection
because you know capitalism is brutal
uh it's creative destruction most
businesses that get started won't
make it even if they make it they won't
go 10 years
or 20 years and by the time a business
enters the
s p 500 it has already passed its prime
you know so it's already the the
elements which will lead to its decline
are mostly already in place and very few
businesses last 50 years
almost no businesses last 100 years so
it's it's pretty hard
[Music]
you